okay let's hear from some of you in the
audience via the david pakman show
discord which you can find at
davidpakman.com
slash discord we use discord
instead of a so-called real phone number
now
i feel that the audio quality has
improved
i feel substantively arguably things
have also improved okay
let's start today with ezana from
atlanta georgia
asana you were on the air
hi david hello taking my call pleasure i
wanted to
ask you in light of the derek chauvin
verdict
yes do you think that the conversations
that are being had around police
brutality
systemic racism more broadly
are doing more harm or damage to the
left in terms of
gaining public support and getting the
people we want elected
i don't think that they're doing more
harm than good but i
question whether they're always doing
that much good
does does that make sense yeah yeah i i
kind of see you just saying can you
yeah i mean i i think that sometimes the
conversation on the left
around police brutality and around race
is disproportionate to the degree to
which something is a problem
in the real world so like as an example
um i'm not a class reductionist so class
reductionism would be
any problem that seems to be about
race or ethnicity or religion really
it's actually about class and if you
deal with inequality in class
the problem gets resolved that's class
reductionism i'm not a class
reductionist and so
but but given that there are times when
as an example
when you look at the number of
uh of of black americans killed by
police in the year
and you look at the amount of
conversation about it
versus the degree to which economic
factors are a huge role player
um in poverty and therefore in education
and therefore
in being in neighborhoods where there is
more crime
and where police are paying more
attention rightly or wrongly right i
mean that's that's a whole other debate
sometimes it feels as though the
conversation has gotten a little bit
out of sync with the proportion to which
these different things
are problems and of course these are all
problems but i would like to see the
conversation maybe a little more
fine-tuned like here let me give you one
other really specific example
it's become very popular now
for police departments and corporations
to announce
in response to what's going on we will
be sending
our officers or our employees to
anti-bias
trainings to learn about implicit bias
is there evidence that that actually
reduces the types of incidents that are
problematic i've looked for it and i
can't find it so i i worry
that it's more of like a pr thing than
it is actually dealing with the problem
yeah i think i definitely think there
is sort of you know a certain degree of
virtue signaling
that's going on and i don't
think it's always in bad faith i think a
lot of the time it is in good faith
i agree but i'm uh the the overall thing
that
i i'm thinking of this is just more
broadly
i'm just wondering if this is you know
some of the reasons why like trump had
so much support
um if if we're going too far with some
of these issues
and especially now because i genuinely
thought
january 6th was going to be like the
death of the republican party
it never is the fact that yeah yeah but
the fact that
like trump did an interview the other
night on hannity and that
they seem to still have a lot of energy
on their side
i i'm wondering if it's coming back to
these type of issues that
are the reasons for that yeah i don't
i don't i'm not ready to say that it is
you know i i've expressed the
the concerns i have but i wouldn't be
ready to make such a sweeping statement
okay all right my friend thank you so
much for the call very much appreciate
it always very very important issue and
one i think that
must be dealt with in a realistic way
you know we shouldn't pretend things are
different if something's a problem we
should deal with the problem rather than
just insisting it's not a problem
let's go next to stephanie i think it's
from richmond is that stephanie from
richmond virginia
no hi it's uh stephanie from richardson
texas oh sorry
it was cut off richardson texas welcome
stephanie
hi how are you i'm doing well good um
actually i wasn't really had anything
prepared i'm just kind of listening
today
but i actually had a quick and i did
start thinking about a question i wanted
to ask um
about uh since i'm in texas we have a
lot of issues as you may know
um okay say more about that yeah
ahead no no i was going to say tell me
more about the issues yeah
well no there's where do i start so it's
like obviously i watched your uh your
clip
the other day about um how matthew we
say mcconaughey
from texas but matthew mcconaughey is
there's he's
thrown his hat in the ring which i don't
know if he would even you know be a
decent um
candidate but it is evident of how
people are starting you know our
climate's changing hopefully and i'm
thinking
like personally i'm wanting to get more
active and like um
uh not i don't know i don't know what
i'm trying to say but like being
more proactive in raising awareness and
so i wouldn't really know how to start
with all that since you seem pretty
educated on the subject of you know
educating people um i know once the
government
government um races uh candidacy starts
and people start getting um
out there i'm hoping beto decides to run
again
and everything like that and i'm just
hoping like i would like some
like advice or tips that you could offer
as far as being um
someone i'm not necessarily shy per se
but i'm not super proactive
so like any suggestions you can throw
out there about like
being someone who i know that oh boy
stephanie we just lost you we just lost
you for a second we just lost you there
stephanie but
here's so here's the thing the great
thing about being a
a progressive in texas is
there are so many opportunities to get
involved to try to unseat a right-wing
nut
so whether it's city councils
mayor's races a gubernatorial race
whatever
there's no shortage of opportunities and
you can really make an impact whereas
you know the truth is you can
participate in local races anywhere
but sometimes it's less interesting to
look at replacing
you know a left-wing democrat with a
five percent more left-wing democrat
it's like
you know okay i mean it's a move to the
left but sometimes it's less rewarding
there are so many opportunities in texas
that you could really get involved in
that and you know if you don't want to
be knocking on doors or calling people
because that's not your personality
there's other things that can be done
you can contact people via text message
there's so many campaigns to get
involved in right and that's what i
think i'm leaning towards because i've
obviously become more uh politically
aware over the last
few years and it's you know something
that i as having a teenage daughter
there's things that are going to start
impact her life so i definitely want to
get involved and
be a little bit more of a you know a
game changer because we
like i said we have a lot of problems we
need to fix them here because
i don't think we're going to fix them
all but i i'm sad because
texas really is a great state but we're
getting such a bad reputation
that makes me very sad what um
richardson texas is that in a more blue
or red area i don't i'm not familiar
with it
i think that's pretty red we're um and
uh
we're our we're kind of um north of or
suburb of dallas
but yeah as you know dallas is pretty
blue and so is austin oh you know
houston and things like that but some of
the the suburbs are definitely a little
bit more red but i think that
my area might be a little bit more
purple i'm hoping
so that you know it's gonna be it's
changing because we have a pretty
diverse um community here where i live
so it's like
hopefully things are gonna start to i
don't know change
all right well plenty of opportunities
to get involved stephanie keep us posted
thanks you have a great day all right
stephanie from texas
great to hear from her why don't we go
next to uh oh i don't know let's go to
rob from east hampton how about
uh hello hello you're on the air oh this
is exciting
um so um i guess i have two questions
but i'll start with the first one
um so the first one i would ask is what
is one position
you used to hold but you sort of changed
your mind on
now one position i used to hold but i've
changed my mind
on that's i mean a lot of economic stuff
where
you know my initial introduction to
economics in high school
and early in college was just straight
neoclassical economics
and now that i've you know studied
everything from behavioral economics to
marxian economics and everything in
between i i have a much more
uh i would call it real world view
rather than the theoretical neoclassical
view
okay interesting um i asked that because
i
used to like i was a big proponent for
medicare for all
okay um and then after last year um you
know i kind of see that okay
yeah you know the majority of the
population doesn't want medicare for all
so
um i sort of like you know change my
views or i guess i've compromised more
i would say now hold on a second that's
interesting you
what you're not saying you changed your
view on medicare for all because you
found out something about it that you
didn't like
it sounds like you're saying you changed
your view because other people don't
like it
um just in terms of electability it's
not it's
realistically i feel like it's not gonna
happen um just because
not that many people um people support
medicare for all but when it comes to
sort of like the intricate details
that's where you kind of see like
support falling off
yeah you're not wrong and i've talked
about that data from the kaiser family
foundation before
which is not part of the the firm kaiser
permanente
my view on this has been i want to get
to universal coverage
with um affordability
and a reasonable standard of care and
in order to do that there's a lot of
different ways
that you can approach it different
countries have approached it in
different ways
i'm not married to medicare for all and
i have a long segment about
other ways it could be arranged as long
as we get to the right
as long as we get to the finish line i'm
open to different ways of running the
race
definitely definitely agree there um i
just have a really strong bias because i
strongly dislike insurance companies so
i would just prefer a medicare fall
system but
again electability wise it isn't the the
most popular thing
um the second question i had and kind of
having a difficulty wording it but
um given biden's handling of the
situation at the border
do you think this and sort of i would
say his lack of
outreach to the hispanic community
during the um
2020 election do you think this can kind
of impact how
um you know midterms go in 2022 i don't
think that what will impact the midterms
is joe biden's outreach or lack of
outreach to the latino community i think
that what will impact the 22 midterms
are is how does the biden administration
react
to right-wing media and republican
elected officials
successfully making immigration
a much bigger issue than it was six
months ago we just looked at polling
which showed that in june of 2020
28 of americans believed that illegal
immigration was a big issue
last month 48 of americans believed
illegal immigration was a big issue this
is a win for republicans because they
know
trump failed on kovid and biden has high
approval on it
they know trump failed to jump start
vaccination and joe biden has a really
high approval on it
the the 1.9 trillion stimulus that biden
did has really high approval so what
republicans
are doing is saying let's come up with
something to shift attention to they've
chosen
immigration and it's working so now that
half the country says it's a serious
issue the question is how does biden
deal with it i don't think it's
it's it's outreach to latino voters i
think
it's what does the perception become
over how joe biden is handling the issue
and we don't know yet what it'll be
because we still have a while until the
2022
midterms okay well thank you so much for
taking my questions
all right my pleasure rob from east is
it right is it east hampton new york or
massachusetts
uh massachusetts wow okay what what's
your top restaurant in east hampton
right now
um not gonna lie kisara yeah
yeah yeah i can't go wrong with kisara
yep um all right good
okay thanks for the call rob very very
good um
let's take a very quick break but if
you're holding don't hang up because
we're taking more calls momentarily
quick break and right back after this